24 лютого все лежить і в тому світі шуя-щу
торнацтво Росія просто займаючись
атерором вона у них якусь стратегію
Миколи придбала Донбас Крим кухарським
виноку армії трохина просто жінка і
вставляти квест
чоловіки промо-гли
Маркуса Валерію вітаю вас зазвучай
самі представляємо у наших
багатою різьблених амплуа і хоче, щоб ви
представилися хто такі Маркус
Ну і за раз створи ти владні бойові
підрозділ я тут
у променевої кільки є люди яких
у всіх собак дають щоб
церкви дрижав став на екрані в Україні та
я дала
Таку форму крихти без ні
ши підпорядкуємо з актуального Росія
обстрілює енерготечну інфраструктуру
буквально сьогодні нове обстріл по всій
Україні До парша атакував і дроном і
Камікадзе, що ви думаєте про таку
Росію
виникнення
легко
видно буде
на майданчик повномасштабного вторгнення
мені вдалося Путін спочив і потроху
труситися ременя ти за мною місця і
сало
в основному Росія просто займаючись
терором Стріли піщатові окервали
Кримський
місцева вона просто начебто злі ще більше
українців
і дали нам можна вивести
вимагати з брови на заході А за полювання
ще більше
і проводити з брови нам давати
тупі імпульсний Коло
військовий закрут віркен небо топішу
воювати доучилася до збору упризу для
того, хто його повний пояснити чим
цінне для України киркін Я просто хочу
щоб вся паскуда гнила у в'язниці
український
що приводу інформації
Я думаю інформації може дати дістати
виду піти в Криму 14 уроці та на
Донбасі та про збуті Боїнг
щоб паскуда сиділа У в'язниці та Миколи
звитана вийшла
на 200 наших дітей
у нас
щоб усі показу
його вирішили змінити І все-таки вона
колу з наших
ширина в лику кільки слюди
мідним обидва нічого проти буде він
випадку веденегу живого в наших руках
кори Сибіру шинеш видно Артуру про ваш
підрозділ точніше стегно зробив до
створнякова видав дуже у травні генштаб
доручення займатися 40 сьомим батальйоном
штурмовим Чому саме Вам
не пропала нібито думає
просто запропоновано кинути Бог яйця і
посадні напрусів
мені Чудово рухалося у розвитку
плавати нова погода все буде засікала
Хто ті люди, хто служити вранці
ціна гра ще люди на Планеті хоче в
багатою Росія
Так просто інфантильно
а з прагматичної точки погляд і працює
у нас слухати Якутії солдатиф слухати
бізнеси it компанії
розумів на нашу компанію ось наш скелет
закимов робому целюди абсолютно різні
звань і пусат усьому Ми раді думки з
людьми йти там на Посаді там Стрільців
Давай дізнаємося, що в тебе Люда наша рити
тому в нас
дзвонять Облога німа ніякого суду його
значення У нас тут сире
головне
Зебра все
айтішники кандидати наук
Тут люди таких Посад
і такого ж тіло досвіду
ми всіма людьми на тики бригали на
компанію могла AppStore ти теж писали
то не думаю що він і погодься пися
Пара тут всі зародки того що
росіянок бувають Чому головна фішка
ув'язнення на результат вона на процес
наших людей
якорнує наших людей і нам начхати що
він їх записував весь комод насика
вийшов він і в міряти нас нахвалю я
формальність Юра вічно приклад там
Забутий штат просто зародки цифри
а поставлять і людей на посади просто
заряди цифри
обидва ось так вимагає директива
залом Бога то моменті Вікі вимагаючи армія
просто зараза цифри
цифри знайду допоможе а я кисть Так ми
накриваємо в стегно озері людей
Екіпаж тут ніби перебуваю шпалери кіно на
петхольяти і ціни виживуть солдат
сержанчів офіцер скільки ж ніг у нього
[музика]
видоснувших педрозильїв я думаю можна
сказати що багатий кажуть Нормально
персонаж може дати і люди
а ви ще раз втикався з таким
упряжним став ним дощик просто по
факту він
надивайся на їхню фізичну з
проможність розумову едос там роботи
житія зараз емоції треба є
просто жінка і вставляти квест
впасти з початку батальйон полк зараза
то ми на Руся вам питання
максимальний жарт та ефективно
то ми вже Бригада наш полк тепер уже
бригаду розум чсд кількума кедро зробимо
мови ми будемо його протити розум чекає
дуже ваш до робота
При такому от Затишок саме наш
педрістю
їжі на наш шанс навіть цієї дуеліту
настав руку
допомагаючи ефективніше наскільки знаю що
до вашого стегна зробив Його витратив я
говорю з українською що не знаєш
українську ІЗО всім так люди на моїй
бути здану
крутих зусиль і парамовані українську
тут і я забудуться умовку за раз у нас
я і на замку
йти не знаю якими можете укували все
українською
Німеччині з Грузії він і горе справним
акцентом російську в таких випадках
відомо ми
закриваємо це дуже
але ми розуміємо обставинами людей на
толкова Людмила Це мої заради
Ну ось а леот що совість про саме
українців то злишся Ми вимагаємо
виставопроводили з півбайседи з людьми
якісь трапоти в полицях Я б сам би
фізично
був проти ватку кисть людей Скільки
було заявок тисяч п'ять Про кого повідомляла
Я вже не служив шукав служив
Я замовив посадмінку ж механіку
І як ми можемо охоронець водити дружині
Вадим механік
Покажіть весь потік
ділюся весь школи ковзанка в ідей Вже 200
років тому їх Посада ваша називається
високий вкласти акумулятор доброта не
знаю запитавши шойн у світі в принципі
в руку вкажу, що вже відриваючи
повномасштабна вівторок чого ви
навчилася
у YouTube може йти хоч фондів виходив
на кисть курси Які організовував
нічого я його на взявши Яни більше
люди не збереглися до новичків.
хоче мішка яка може бути і на честь
держава нам
призначену частину
джедали ще дасть імпортну з брови
зустрічалася
йому вдалося Барахти творчості
з Барахти люди є
по протяжку
максимально тон у цій скроні
чайні вкладається в одну подію
кулі люди на нові беруть участь в армії
Часто у нього творчості люди не
отрафуються
і люди на протворити у квадратного
сама ось
перпендикулярно та паралельно круглі
носи квадратний код
коротше про армію зміїною пухирте в ній
було і писати 14 рік до цілої години
багата пустельна зміна якщо 22 хоче
змінитися той період і заріс надійно
прийняв цієї б у нас з березня 15 по 20
пар ший ми велі
стабілізаціями від звинувачення і можна було
займатися формами
логісти відмінювання
взаємотоксиконаміку Zara сопротіону
фронт
щоб фронт у сильнодхіни боєприпаси на
автомобілем хворим на їжаків людьми
Але об'єктивно у нас в армії на височай
порядку Окей
Мамба ніби
масштабної Венеції протягом години для
загиблих реформ буде добре
радикальна споживання української армії
Якось Хлопці за тренди коротко з такою
проспективі
а за раз будете від ринку на Можливо
дещо ти і знову не нашої України в
принципі
то ми вже тягнемо маяки
а там витягтимемо українські армії за
раз ви зустрічалися брови та боєприпаси
чорні висоти
якось в одному інтерв'ю ви зараз маєте
адже спочатку що за раз той травмі для
України вуса складається так добрі до
телевізор може складатися ось сьогодні в
жовні якуться складається для
рухи дні
краще буде
кувалли заланського потім сказала що
Зеленський красень
заякозі умового зможе знову змінити
свою донку велику побачу ці ідеї
і кинути на прямку з
тоне Наша Україна
інша вина Русі Бог ще співчував
і
я б там дали на буллу лише одне
Володимир Олександрович та Валерію
Федоровичу своє життя я буду в яскравий
якву
наділи на майданчик повномасштабного
вівторка
в Sava вирішувалося
і селюди витерла нашу Україну, але будь
такого простору України світильник за
раз
можуть нікого не було і гнізда ще
щоб його вибухнеш поліції
Олександр і свою посаду прицілюючи
27 сотки ви самі замислювалася
Боже я не знаю дах змінити
за раз моя справа Видно у вас дошку
теж несуть саморізи у Фейсбуку 160 тисяч
передплатників Інстаграмі 240 тисяч
наскільки доросла кільки є підписки
вписали 24
Інстаграмі
тут уже на сотню сотню тисяч
Instagram аудиторія
а мовчки аудиторії на той контент такі
продуктів у них нас кути васикалів
винна Всі ці речі про добрих
росіян це загинули з 24 лютого всі
стали таки школі
називається 4 лютого все лежить і в тому
світлі
жартує ринковість
українці робота
що вона вам даємо соціальний властивості
капітал якими вихрестовими дорожитками
нашого педроздю
кохає вона зможе Ну за раз не
пораниш а так ну там монетизація була але
на патроні у Азаров усі вирушають на
армія
але зачепи в руку
мільйони три рядів
[музика]
у вас ще узми називають що не Богом
війни то секс-символом провини я Квеста ось
такого титулу терпіння
розумінням до людей екіпажу та загине
ми на неї часто обзиваю все
смейтери Ну звичайно
це все залишу все клин астрис гумару
клей
може
побачить лише я протоколів
Тобто можна за раз простити І що я
телефонувати купити рибу
голос наподобаєте Поклик зовнішність
розтлумачення всім скупість так
що
тоді знаходите цих щось би накриті
кують
то означає просто говорити що вона верстат
нібито бадшота закиньшить я Ірина я не
боюся
я буду пароплави
ось одно не коена закінчиться
на початку всього повномасштабного
турне я покидаю там ти два тижний Путін
до кредиту до травми це все старостім
гумором і покидаю палити їх Все
прощалося ми якраз і ялинки на бульбашці
з пімафи інтернет
Істрі і там я засріли як жартую за
мінімум на Рік він же за раз можна сміливо
його вказати мінімум Рік
Але об'єктивно точно вже на Рік
Донбас Крим кухарним
просто у сісі раніше будуть упрятися
більше в тому я будуть результати вся
пудеї в середовищі не Русі і в середовищі не
руської армії
єлопи самі запустили Просто змагання
з собою
чуждася ним Не виливати ці процеси
і наскільки
адже я не знаю його закласти
він не лякають середовища не свого краю, то ще
розумний програють
ми ще на Першому кути голе хвилі
дякую вам за всіх робота і
товариш
жертвуючи у шкірного світ фронт
інсулити
у кальярні
пропустивши Хто такі чувак поспішає на
питання Дякую
дяку за 1000 робота на своєму фронті
спасибі